this video be introduced to a theory of
mine in which Theon Greyjoy was no
longer capable of producing gears has
actually already produced their back in
the second season and therefore if we
are to assume that he will eventually be
defeated yar on the other hand will die
fighting urine wealth iam will be
crowned the king of the Iron Islands the
same air would be of the great
importance says it would prevent house
Greyjoy from extinction
this theory is supported with quite a
few clues from both the show and the
book series so let's just jump into it
in the second episode of the second
season aboard the meijer ham a ship
taking him to Pike Theon descends to the
captain's cabin which he has taken for
his own the captain's daughter waits in
his bed naked after a bit of small talk
she hopes the untoned lace his breeches
and tells him that he'll be a king one
day having an intimate relationship with
her most probably resulted with her
being pregnant but it's also important
to holiday-themed told her about the
Ironborn tradition of taking salt wives
whereupon she begged him to take her as
one assault wife is essentially a bound
concubine in Ironborn culture they are
usually the women kidnapped during raids
however children born sold wives are not
considered bastards but they do rank
behind children for Lords rock wife in
iron man's true spouse in the line of
succession which in this case is not
important since Theon is no longer
capable of producing a child in Song of
Ice and Fire series of epic fantasy
novels on which Game of Thrones is based
there are even more clues there leading
towards a conclusion that the captain's
daughter Julie got pregnant with Ian's
child it books those to share very
similar scene as in the show with one
difference being film sentence about her
getting pregnant on the show up on
revealing the Theon that her father will
punish her and call her names if he
doesn't take her with him and make her
his salt wife Fiona responded with a
statement that he hasn't paid her but
that's not the same case in the books in
the book sofyan on her confession of
fear responds with as many times as I
thought you're likely with child it's
not every man who has the honor of
raising a king's bastard
perhaps this was a bit too obvious for
shadow and clue to be included in the
show later in the books it's also been
highlighted that Theon is confident that
he got the captain's daughter pregnant
while on the show the two haven't met
ever since in the books they did see
each other once again a few weeks after
their first encounter as her ship was
for bed and told bike were quite some
time so that the mainland could not be
warned in advance that the Aran Islands
have declared their independence and his
film went back to the dogs in the
company of his sister the two saw each
other the captain's daughter calls out
Theon trying to convince him to speak
with her and to take her as his sole
while bad feeling just ignored her
perhaps she was trying to tell him she
was indeed pregnant with his child and
therefore convinced him to take her as
his sole wife and if true that's
definitely something we will learn in
Game of Thrones finale there's one more
clue that was in favor to this theory of
mine it's from George RR Martin's cider
book the world of Ice and Fire the
untold history of Westeros in the game
of Thrones in that book we learned that
house grader had to be continued at
least once resolved sons of salt wives
there's written the Dalton grey jury
also known as red Kraken had never taken
a rock wife to spouse that had lots of
salt wives and therefore his closest
tears were his salt sons if we stop for
a moment to think about it this could be
one of many for sheriffs and close that
Thune actually has a son and heir that
will be introduced in the show once gern
is defeated Yara killed and themed
crowned as demons huge relief that has
great evil not extinct with empathy
Loretto continued through his salt son
once he dies otherwise I wouldn't see
the point of all of those clothes in
both the books and the show regarding to
captain daughter's pregnancy there would
not either be a point in George RR
Martin's introduction with different
approach to marriage and inheritance
surrounding Ironborn if the history will
not repeat itself once again and house
Greyjoy will not be continued through
the insult son